such strength and clarity and just like
joe's uninspiring state of the union
speech last night instead of showing
real leadership on the world stage joe
basically read off a wishlish
wish list of repackaged build back broke
proposals and he offered no plan to curb
inflation or no plan to lower gas prices
no plan to secure the border no plan to
reduce violent crime no plan to counter
china and by the way taiwan i would
argue keep a close eye on it probably
not going to be that long and he didn't
even bother to mention the 13 u.s
soldiers who died as a result of his
disastrous withdrawal from afghanistan
or the americans who have been trapped
behind enemy lines today by the way is
day 200 joe abandoned them and by the
way joe and the media they not only
abandoned them they turned the page and
they moved on pretty unforgivable now
joe also didn't seem to have much of a
plan to assist the people of ukraine but
he did manage to call them iranians
leaving the vice president a little bit
embarrassed take a look
putin may circle keeve with tanks
but he'll never gain the hearts and
souls of the iranian people
he'll never he'll never extinguish their
love of freedom
[Applause]
ukrainian joe not iranian ukrainian
one of many awkward moments from a very
simple speech frankly one that could
have been written by a fifth grader that
still proved too difficult for our
struggling commander-in-chief you decide
we spent months building coalitions of
other freedom-loving nations in europe
we're cutting off russia's largest banks
in the international financial system
preventing russia's central bank from
defending the russell rubin ruble our
forces not going to europe to fight
ukraine and a pound of ukrainian people
the proud proud people pound for pound
ready to fight with every inch of
earnings they have you can't build a
wall high enough to keep out
a
a a vaccine the vaccine can stop
the spread
of these diseases
ban assault weapons with high-capacity
magazines a little bit 100 rounds
you think the deer are wearing kevlar
vests
and may god protect our troops
thank you
go get him
go get him go get who
uh trying to emulate larry the cable
guys you know get her done i mean what
was that all about anyway meanwhile as
joe was mumbling and bumbling his way
through a very simple speech our 81 year
old speaker of the house nancy pelosi
uh was having her own malfunction
in a very bizarre way now take a look at
her very joyous reaction to biden's
comments about
burn pits in the iraq war you maybe can
explain this to me because i can't iraq
and faced in afghanistan face many
dangers
one being stationed at bases breathing
in toxic smoke from burn pits
many of you have been there
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
these burn pits that incinerate waste
can someone explain that to me anyway i
digress and then there's vice president
kamala harris and kamala harris she
brilliantly described the conflict in
europe like this quote ukraine is a
country in europe it exists next to
another country called russia
russia is a bigger country russia
decided to invade a smaller country
called ukraine so basically that is
wrong
okay
when you add these three together we're
really screwed and the state of our
union is not strong hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else